all right he was the Rookie of the Year
in the National League last year his Los
Angeles Dodgers have hit a little bit of
a speed bump here in August but not this
man personally who comes bearing gifts
courtesy of metrics fitness nutrition
brand the spokesman of that as well as
of the Los Angeles Dodgers Cody
Bellinger good to see you sir hey
they're doing fine I am doing just fine
we just showed some some footage of you
in the Little League World Series from
back in the day your dad what was he the
manager of that team first base coach
we had manager who was the third-base
coach okay and your dad was a manager of
a team later on that he took the little
world sir reason no he just as much that
year yeah and then my brother played and
they lost in the regionals they they
never never quite made it right he was a
manager of that team and that and then
like Big Al you hit you hit a dinger
headed a yeah you get an actual dinger
at one ding who else from that team has
made it to the majors anybody else
nobody I'm still close with you know a
few of them but I think and then one one
still playing but other than that just
me what's your first baseball memory
first baseball memory yeah man man I
wish I had an answer for you I don't
know what did you remember we're going
to I mean you'd you'd have been ages
four to six in the Yankee clubhouse
hey age seven yeah when you were in the
Angels clubhouse your dad was in the
majors for four years do you remember
being in the I remember the clubhouse
for me during the games I was in the
playroom all me me and the kids were we
weren't watching the games we're in the
playroom do you remember where you were
in the playroom with Andy Pettit Andy
Pettit son Josh we were really good
friends we still talked here and there
but yeah him and we had a Titan II group
when my dad played for the Yankees so we
had a lot of kids growing up together
playing in the playroom not watching the
games and hanging out in the clubhouse
so we kind of had the life no kidding do
you do you remember going to the World
Series at all is that I do I remember
which one oh one when they lost I
remember that one you know Arizona hey
because I've seen video of it but for
whatever reason I remember sitting in
the stands in Arizona and watching the
d-backs beat the Yankees took Game seven
you're talking
I was in the stands that day - yeah much
older man yeah I don't know I think I
was much older
I remember being I remember being there
when Rivera came out and struck out the
side in the eighth and I was in a
section surrounded by a bunch of player
Diamondback wives who are crying because
they thought this thing was over yep and
then then I think we all thought it was
over and then the ninth inning happened
you know unheard of for Mariano Rivera
pretty much so you were in this you you
do remember being there I'll do do you
pick did you pick anything up at all do
you think I don't think so not at all I
think the thing I learned maybe not even
learn just being in the clubhouse right
being around baseball you know my whole
life has helped me I don't know if I
learned a specific thing but I think
like I said just being around the guys
at such a young age
mmm which is a huge benefit for me now
we try to reach your dad last year and
he's you know kind of private because
he's we call tweet we called his
firehouse to talk to him after he threw
BP to you for the home run derby what
was that what was that like for you guys
to go through that for the home run
derby last year I think that was the
coolest experience of the year last year
obviously the World Series was yeah
unbelievable in itself but having him
throw to me in in the home run derby was
special really nerve-wracking I don't
know if he was nervous I was definitely
nervous walking up to the plate but that
was I thought it was gonna be cool but
it blew it out of the water it's about
to say I mean that's got to be as great
as it comes there's your dad there you
are
you've made it to the all-star game
you're having a great rookie season he's
pitching to you you're in a home run
derby the whole country is watching
that's amazing amazing looking back at
it it was crazy you know I think during
the year everything just kind of happens
right so quick that you're just kind of
enjoying it didn't really have time to
reflect on it till after the season but
sure yeah I think the the Derby was cool
especially the new format they got with
the time that is I think they've nailed
it
inhaled it I went with my kids this year
and the excitement of the final round
with schwöre BER who I think up I called
him was like hey he's least like a fire
hydrant with a Cubs hat on his head
you know and just cranking them out one
after another it was a billion degrees
and then Bryce Harper comes back with
the extra time Knox went out of the park
more than fifteen or thirty seconds ago
he hit like eight or nine out so how
tough how tough is that it's hard it's
nerve wracking and usually when you hit
BP you got a turtle above you and when
you're hit with no turtle it does make a
difference it's kind of but when you
explain my turtle is the batting cage
above your head that you're hitting and
see if you saw a ball off it goes into
the Kate instead of the instead of the
stands right you're not hitting with it
with a cage it's you feel open and a
little awkward at first but I don't know
I think the two-minute mark and get one
timeout you're pretty tired so it's hard
but it like I said you got a lot of
adrenaline going and of course now did
Cody Bellinger here in the Rich Eisen
show did you did you tell your dad hey
you gotta throw it here I mean did you
give him a look at some times if he
didn't nail the spot did you I think he
started to figure out a few seconds in
where I was swinging where I was hitting
him and he just tried to hit that spot
every single time right up and in do you
think it affected the way you played
this season in the second half no I
think that's a huge myth there rumor
it didn't affect me hasn't affected
Harper this year hasn't it all it hasn't
affected Muncie really this year I don't
think it hasn't an effect at all you
know you take BP every day so that's
just a glorified BP
so would you do it again I would do it
again I think I would do enjoy a lot
more if it was at home for another home
crowd well 2020 that's right it's right
here
coming up and you give tips to Muncie
that guy was cranking it out to I
thought he had a chance to win that
first shot to the first round he was
great but it's just again it's so tiring
yeah I got a call he does it every day
in BP so I thought for sure he had a
chance
and Turner water hitting coaches
throwing strikes and that's all you can
ask for is hater okay let's take a
60-second break come back I wanna hit
you on the current state of the Dodgers
and what's in the bag that red bag that
you got here right right that's my gift
for you the gifts for me yet I've never
seen before because well in terms of me
or ever ever planetary closet even came
out yet
I feel like it's that pulp fiction
moment like it's gonna open up and it's
gonna glow gold just some cookie bytes
okay chef golden cookie bytes fantastic
all right let's take a break back in 60
seconds with last year's National League
Rookie of the Year Los Angeles Dodger
Cody Bellinger and your phone calls
there all at Ryan Leaf making his way to
the studio to
[Music]
parties random metric shirt he's got a
metrics bag we're gonna find out what's
inside the bag the hat belongs to Cody
Bellinger the Los Angeles Dodgers during
the commercial break Chris Cody you turn
to me and I was telling you how when I
pitch wiffle ball to my kids you know I
want to make sure it's the right spot mm
you know the pressures on right there
and I told one of told you my youngest
son is a lefty and he watches you
playing baseball and he knows you know I
gotta hit that sweet spot he's got a
sweet left-handed swing and then you
asked me are they playing coach pitch
right now and my kids in a league where
it's half coach pitch and it's half kids
pitch age seven and look you're giving
me right now is kind of a look that I
gave the people who are in charge of the
league League what do we what are we
doing here because my son looks forward
to hitting all week he got up to the
plate in his last game of the year okay
and the first pitch and then we were so
excited it's last game there he's
batting second it was fantastic didn't
have to wait long first pitch Cody from
a kid hits him right in the ribs and he
goes down and the arm who is terrific
this is take your base so my son starts
you know he's crying he's hurt yes so
dad comes out in my flip-flops and I you
know make sure he's okay
but at that point I tell my son go back
to home plate take your cot and the arms
like no he's got to take first and for a
split moment I was that dad on the field
with everybody looking at me Julie tell
the umpire what he needs taking his base
I said to him he's been waiting all week
to hit what are we teaching him that he
gets hit by a pitch he's got to take his
base when a seven-year-old who's got no
cotton you know I didn't want to
criticize a seven-year-old right there
that's tough what situation to be in
what do you think I mean rules are the
rules I think if you get hit you got to
take the base but I don't know if you
can put seven-year-olds you know they
don't know where the ball is going thank
you so the games don't really count so
you know I'm on both sides right
you should be able to hit too if you
want okay Thank You Cody Bellinger I
gotcha all right your dad your dad would
you prove with of that sort of yeah okay
he would approve Cody Bellinger the Los
Angeles Dodgers here on the show what's
going on with the team right now Cody I
know that's a macro question but it
seems that you guys have hit a bit of a
lull here would you agree with that yeah
I agree I mean we had a good series in
Seattle right before we came across some
good pitching and you know I think we've
been through last year we lost 14
straight in September last year and
everyone thought the world was ending we
weren't even gonna make playoffs and you
know here we are again the same
situation obviously we had a little bit
of a lead when we were losing last year
but I don't know for whatever reason we
go through these stretches as a team and
and we snap out of it so not that it's
gonna come easy but I think we have on
paper the best team in the National
League so once it all starts coming
together we're gonna be perfectly fine
no I know it's a team effort and and and
it all comes down to what you do innings
one through nine but lately the bullpen
has struggled to hold leads even kenley
jansen coming back has been touchable in
a way that he has not been how difficult
is it to lose games continuously when
you're leading and it's late and
suddenly you're going back to the
clubhouse without a W yeah it's hard I
think it's hard for everybody on the
team it's hard in for the coaching staff
it's hard on the players well like I
said we have so no might not believe us
we still have full confidence in the
guys we put out there
I think we've held we've dealt a lot of
injuries this year a lot of key guys
went down early and we've just been
trying to grind it out but once the time
comes down and we need to start winning
games like we do now i think i think
we're perfectly fine and what happened
last year that you're trying to
replicate this year that you snapped out
of it how does that happen it just
you're playing every day you're you're
you're grinding every single day at
seven o'clock and sometimes things just
don't go your way we had we've had
plenty of opportunities with guys and
bass we're a few inches that way or a
few inches this way we get a hit I just
way the game goes sometimes you hit it
right out people and no euro for
whatever
guys and runners in scoring position but
like I said with that I think we're
gonna be perfectly fine and is there a
player's only meeting that's happened
are you gonna have one
no we've had we have meetings every day
I said it's never lack of preparation
for us where we prepare every day like
we did last year getting to the World
Series it's just a matter of doing the
job and you know unfortunately we didn't
do it last series but we scored 20-plus
runs a series before that so that's just
the way baseball goes Cody Bellinger
here in the Rich Eisen show a scale of
one to ten with one being crazy and ten
being really crazy how crazy is yasiel
Puig ten how crazy I'll give him up I'll
give him a five in between crazy and
really yeah he's awesome like in the
clubhouse he's he's always supportive
but he licks his bat you know after a
foul ball what kind of crazy is that I
don't know you've never done that I've
never done that you've never have you
ever kissed your bad you ever done
anything like that I've think I'll
honestly I'm gonna kiss my bat for like
a hit but not after a foul ball mm-hmm
you know licking the bad in front of
40,000 people what about snapping it
over your leg have you ever been able to
do that no no do you want to don't want
to do it back and I've done it like on
outside was like can I actually do this
and I don't think I have a shot yet so
if it's ever if it's ever cracked or you
know in any way shape or form broken you
can give it a whirl then I'm gonna do it
down in the tunnel in case I don't snap
it very good not embarrassed I like I
like it yeah I like it until I know I
can do it is the shift is the shift in
baseball Cody Bellinger is it biased
against left-handed hitters I think so I
think you can't put a guy in left center
against a righty because if he hits
they're still gonna be a hit you get
hits because of the shift where they
would have been but more often times
than not you're gonna get a hit taken
away you know that's part of the game
now unfortunately but I think it's
definitely disadvantage for lefties
would you bunt if you get shifted enough
would you oh yeah you can bond all the
time but now the third baseman's right
there so you can't even bunt anymore or
the most part yeah but I can't buy not
nobody comes to the game to watch you
bunt no you no chance what I'm saying
but sometimes you need a hit and then
you're gonna buy it so it's base if you
could change anything in Major League
Baseball what would it be
um I would like to have the mound suited
back but that's never gonna happen
what do you mean cuz I want those like
95 you know with the really good
curveball that's just me being a hitter
you know so 60 more time to react 62
feet 63 feet yeah so what is the normal
distance 60 feet 6 inches sir yeah
that'll never happen but that'd be nice
part of you know what I would change
what would you change what I would
change is if there is a scuffle on the
field ok nobody's allowed to lightly jog
in from the bullpen you're not allowed
to come in from the bullpen you can't
come in you got to be on a full sprint
here's what I will do I will walk before
I run figuratively I will say you must
be full sprinting like we've got a time
your ass to get in there like don't just
lightly jog oh I'm coming in I'm doing
this sort of like what happened with the
other day with Puig you know all you
know everyone's just like just jogging
in from the pen you got to either haul
ass or you're not allowed to come in at
all that's what I'm saying
I like that usually how brawls are five
seconds of five to 15 seconds of you
know pushing each other and then it
evens out unless it's like a serious
brawl I haven't been in it's too serious
of a brawl yet and the big leagues well
what happened the other day were you in
you were involved in that Scott I try
grabbing Puig and he's really strong he
got away from me real quick so then I
went right into this to the scuffle of
everything what's going on in there what
do people say a lot of like that a lot
of pushing a lot of uh you know a lot of
a lot of cuss words okay but like I said
at that point the bullpens are in and we
gotta get your team's right here and
then you're gonna get pushed to one side
and then eventually it evens out okay
yeah just this stuff looks really silly
what's going on in the back brother
brand-new cookie bites okay protein
mm-hmm
you can use some after your 40-yard dash
you know okay recover and
oh it won't help me get faster it might
help you get faster who knows all right
open some time let me see these this is
a brand new protein packed snack option
metrics cookie bites everybody yes good
- the chocolate chip one is good all
right here we go
Cody Bellinger that's an unzip in red
metrics bag I'm gonna give you the
chocolate chip kind all right that's
what I'd like to have here we go
and you got a car there's a card in
there - it's a box cookie bites you want
one guys I'm in he's hungry over there
I'm starving
yeah okay I ready I missed that
but that was a good strike that was that
yeah you hit the box on a first lecture
on the first pitch there you go on the
roll here go Mike and get this one
shouldn't be throwing out leave it to
the all-star sticky packaging yeah there
you go works better okay now LG try one
what do you like these what do you like
about these brother well there's a lot
of protein and I'm twelve loft Oh
healthy snacks on the go oh my gosh this
is really good it tastes delicious
chocolate chip chocolate peanut butter
yeah these in the 100 bars are there all
over our Clubhouse they're in my locker
nope they're part of a lot of guys daily
routine okay whether you're just after a
workout I eat one mom sometimes I don't
like to eat a full meal before a game
just so I'm not you know to to fall so I
just eat a bar and I'm ready to go this
is perfect usually right around now at
this time of the show I'm about 1/2
halfway in
you know like 90 minutes in I'm like
feeling a little bit I need a bite there
you go and it's to cookie you know who
doesn't want to cook who doesn't want a
cookie right just like you'd love them
thrown your way every now and then yeah
we all need cookies at Cody underscore
Bellinger great to have you here man
don't be stranger we're practically
neighbors
great to be a chef as ravine and El
Segundo is Nathan next door neighbors
will do it great to be here thank you
are you are you do play did you play
golf I like golf okay you want to take a
couple of putts I'll pipe okay it's like
the only decent part of my game actually
you know what here's what we're gonna do
I know you you you have someplace to be
but I'm gonna keep you after class for
just a couple of minutes let's have a
putt-off contest over there yeah and
who's the best football player on the
Dodgers I saw you one hand Odell Beckham
you sort of did an Odell Beckham catch
the other day yeah I posted on Instagram
it kind of blew up
it was a youth football so a little
smaller that's why no no no no no start
again start again sorry don't start
again start again the football you you
caught was a real football
does it really start against target yeah
okay so that the other day you post it
on Instagram you're one handing a
football right yep our first base coach
was miked up I went back to Seattle so
we had our camera guy there and randomly
happened I just told him was gonna
one-hand it you throw a perfect perfect
pass right here and boom stuck it stuck
it yeah no gloves right you know gloves
no of course not so who's who's who's
the best football player on the Dodgers
on the Dodgers uh-uh
jock was good in high school okay doc
Peterson from what I've heard and from
what he said okay George Lombard a first
base coach was an all-american okay not
me though I didn't play well see you
gotta help you gotta up your your story
game you're a fantastic football player
with a real football and everything Cody
Bellinger is here check it out again the
new Brett protein-packed snack option
metrics cookie bites checking out these
are delicious at Cody underscore
Bellinger as well on Twitter the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience